wade miley said the last time out he
actually felt maybe a little too good
see what we get out of him today what
are you looking for yeah i thought he
was a little bit stiff his last time out
i didn't think he was nearly as loose as
he had been not only in the no-hitter
but in some of the other ball games
and i would think that having the
shorter start last time out he'll be
back to his normal self he pitched very
well against the giants out there
earlier this year let's hope for the
same here tonight
runner on it first one out and now
darren ruff
3-2 sharply grounded the third backhand
pick short way to second india one relay
to first wild ricochets off the railing
of the dugout
gino makes a nice play on this backhand
right here
strong throw to indy at second base
see a little fumble on the exchange i
don't think indy had a good grip on that
ball
now runner at first two outs and here's
evan longoria
payoff
swing in the miss with rough breaking
late
great depth from miley and on the bump
for the giants tonight that's 30 year
old right hander kevin gossman he's
gonna be making his night start of his
2021 campaign he's 3-0 with a minuscule
1.84 era striking out guys for fun this
year 59 and 53 and two-thirds of his
pitch and he's been pretty stingy with
the walks as well with only 12.
castellanos
4-7
with a couple of walks and a home run
so far so he's been on base six out of
nine played appearances in the series
here it comes
he struck him out
with the splitter that had movement
running in
here's suarez
got him
and that'll end the inning a couple of
strikeouts to shut down the reds here in
the first here's stevenson here's the
stretch for the one-two pitch and it's
on the way
fastball right at the knees struck him
out looking
here's barnhart
claudsman slows it down
dubon's got it and he throws them out a
nice play
as a pitcher your first reaction always
try to knock the ball down
and that probably would have been a much
easier play for dubai had he not
deflected it but did a nice job of
readjusting himself going back to the
ball and then he has one play and that's
a bare hand throw across his body and
does a great job
here's slater here it comes
swing and there's a liner to first it's
knocked down by stevenson he picks it up
behind the bag makes the underhanded
flip to miley covering and it's too late
to get the speedy
austin slater and miley standing with
his hands on his hips
i think he thought they got slater out
then you give yourself a chance score to
pass them off the end of the bat one hop
in between you're right he got in front
of it like you're supposed to do but
went over put the glove down and then
the transfer to the hand
made it a little bit longer play might
have been just what it took for austin
slater to get in there buster posey
singled up the middle this first time
grounded left side tries to advance love
by suarez one foot in throw there in
time
posey the final out for the giants here
in the third they will strand one
akiyama waits on gaussman he's hitting
261.
delivers
splitter struck him out swinging
that was the classic came in like a
strike and then just plummeted downward
like it were going over the top of
vernal falls in yosemite
gosmen pitches
swing and a miss he struck it out
lead off man jesse winker
that splitter
off
rough he grabs it and guardsman's there
and
that's all for winker wow we'll see
right here what happened off the bat
it's a split
takes a funky hop he goes to his
backhand probably got on him a little
quicker and he thought but does a nice
job of
a little pirouette making a throw on the
run that's not an easy play with
gaussman moving
but he let him just perfectly gossiping
on the bag where he should be
just a nice play all around
way to stay with it because that ball
hits the ground off the glove it can
have a spin either way
so here's suarez
that ball into left field back talkman
at the wall he leaps he's got it
castellanos turns around
well this is center field playing left
field this is the best outfit for the
giants right here talkman goes back does
a nice job gets a great jump
sizes up the wall and then makes a
perfect timed jump
goes up high points it
wow what a great catch
that is all for stevenson
and the inning is over
six strikeouts for gorsman
so here is chalkman
base hit to left field and dubon is off
and running winker comes up throwing
dubon scores the ball is cut off and the
second base and chalkman is outed second
india made the tag
but the giants have a one-nothing lead
this inning is a giant fulcrum inning
gotta take your shot against gauzeman
and the reds have two on with one out
and here's jonathan india
splitter
longoria one to first to a double play
and the side is retired kevin gausman's
been good once again as he has been all
year once again going six innings
pitched every start this year he's got
at least six innings and eight
strikeouts that's a thousand one career
strikeouts he is not giving wade miley
any room for error
so here's suarez
and he throws one up and longoria is on
the backhand and his throw is perfect
what a play to open up the bottom of the
seventh inning by evan longoria oh and
how nice it is to have a strong arm evan
longoria to the backhand
suarez over the top
going away from him turns and fires a bb
across the diamond
to get suarez by a step
that guy's good over there
here's a tough spot buster posey
five grand slams on his career
buster it's a high fly ball to the left
hit well into the gap it's up against
the wall one runs going to score two
runs are going to score three runs are
going to score
as buster posey clears the bases a
three-run double for buster posey and
the giants have a four-nothing lead so
the last man standing is tucker barnhart
bounced on the ground and this is gonna
do it rough goes to the bag and the
giants have won the first three games in
the series they've also won four in a
row
and they're now 11 games over the 500
mark and what a nice performance a
little scary at the end as it always is
but it's always led by starting pitching
and there was a case against the night
with kevin gausman